And while we're on the, uh, the subject of
policy, we obviously can't talk about policy
right now without discussing US foreign policy,
which Donald Trump unfortunately laid out
quite disturbingly in a tweet this past weekend.
If ran, wants to fight, that will be the official
end of Iran, never threaten the United States
again.
That was a tweet sent on May 19th at 3:25
PM eastern time.
If a ran wants to fight, that will be the
official end of Iran.
Yeah.
There's a reason the president tweeted this
out and the reason is so stupid.
I almost don't want to say it, but I kind
of have to to tell the story.
Fox News at, I think according to media matters,
there's like 3:17 PM ran a story about Iran
and all the threat from Iran.
Iran's threat is growing it show.
Then eight minutes later is a matte.
Gertz was pointing out on Twitter.
Trump tweets this out.
In fact, the president spent his entire Sunday,
by the way, sitting in his big easy chair
watching Fox News and tweeting about it.
It was absolutely disgusting, but nonetheless,
he did it and he said this, he says that that
will be the end of a ran.
Here's the thing, we have former US intelligence
officials, military officials, as well as
former and current military and intelligence
officials in Europe telling us that the threat
from Iran isn't real, or at least it hasn't
increased, which means there's no imminent
threat coming from Iran.
But what's happening on the ground?
One is you have John Bolton in Trump's ear.
Trump doesn't know any better.
So Bolton is likely to get his war with Iran
that he is wanted since day one of the Bush
administration and to Trump's not smart enough
to understand.
He is also one of the people being manipulated
or ran, does not pose any significant threat
today, at least no more so than they had years
ago, which is to say not very much at all.
There's plenty of other countries out there
that probably pose a much bigger threat to
the United States, but some of those countries
are the ones goading us into attacking a ran.
For example, Saudi Arabia, Saudi Arabia claimed
recently that one of their oil tankers, several
of their oil tankers actually had been sabotaged
and they weren't sure if it was a ran by the
way.
They weren't able to conclusively prove that
a ran did this, but they've got their suspicions
and they're also warning us that you guys
have tankers over there near ran and they
may sabotage those.
So what do we do in response?
We send our aircraft carriers over there.
We start with these a flyover missions.
Yeah,
and what that does is that is trying to goad
Iran into attacking us.
We're attempting them, we're daring them.
And why are we doing that?
Because it's worked out pretty well for us
in the past.
Libya in the 1980s we did the same thing.
We flew our planes over, we issued these threats,
but we weren't actually going to attack until
they attacked us.
And then they did.
And then we did
happened in the Middle East in the early nineties
and now we're trying to get it to happen again.
We're sitting there essentially sending our
troops out there as bait to see if for is
going to bite, leaving our tankers over there
as bait to see if a man's going to attack
them.
That's this administration's plan.
And the second something happens, whether
or not they can even prove it's around there
it goes because Trump himself has admitted
that if they attack us, that's going to be
the end of them.
And it's also ironic cause I'm pretty sure
we heard those same arguments before the Iraq
war.
Yeah.
This should be a quick war in and out real
quick.
You wait in the car.
Tom Cotton, a Republican senator who helped
trash the around deer deal, uh, said last
week.
You know, this would be just a couple of days
we'd be in and out.
We'd be done.
We could defeat around.
Never hear from them again.
That never works.
That never happens.
But that's how Republicans thinking.
[inaudible] you can follow me on Twitter at
fair and balanced times.
Garren chosen in for David [inaudible]